veterans are feeling letdown with
president biden's chaotic withdrawal
from afghanistan i recently spoke with
retired service members who served there
and they they had a lot to say
there's four grown men sitting here we
only got five legs
that's that's extra skin in the game you
know what i mean my heart and my mind
has been totally consumed with the
families
of the victims of of the blast to know
those families are hurting in the way
that i know they are it's just man
it hurts
how did it feel to have a marine general
be the one to address the nation
and talk about the taliban the way he
did the day we left it's disgusting it's
impossible
to have a positive emotion about this
whole experience
you can catch my entire interview this
weekend on the big saturday and the big
sunday show at 5 00 pm eastern
all right deagan
do veterans from afghanistan do they
have a right to feel betrayed by this
president they have a right to feel
betrayed or any way they might feel
by what they have had to just witness
yeah
uh in the last few weeks
and
and i think
the american people
feel for them
that
we're united in trying to support them i
everybody i know immediately
texting phone calls to people they knew
who it served and just made made it a
point and i feel like
folks realize that they need to do that
with everybody who has served this
country but i think
we are stronger as a nation but you know
because we've been able to come together
in this moment of just
grief and rage quite frankly
those three veterans i sat down with
they all served in different ways two
different services three different jobs
the one there that got choked up that's
amos benjamin his brother adam benjamin
served with me he's a gold star brother
and a purple heart recipient i mean this
war's taking its toll on him there have
been 2 000 i mean i think 2 300 deaths
in this war we had 13 of them last week
along with almost 200 afghans
shannon do you think that maybe we
haven't even had a chance to process how
catastrophic that single event was i
mean that's why amos is choked up those
13 lives
and not just reflecting on the war but
that single event and i feel like the
the politics of it we haven't even
appreciated how catastrophic that day
was and i it's been good to see a lot of
people speak out publicly and say if you
know a veteran reach out to them check
on them see how they're feeling because
a lot of people feel like that single
event the third i mean it was the 20
years was so brutal and so much was lost
but that event felt very preventable to
a lot of people like it did not have to
happen so we could not owe you and all
of our veterans a bigger debt and to be
checking in to see how you're feeling it
will take time i'm sure to process all
of this but what's been amazing to me is
that so many of the people who are there
fighting and that i'm hearing back
channeling from i'm sure you are i'm
sure everybody at this table is
they're veterans they're people who are
risking their own lives and everything
they have every connection they have
their own money to go back and try to
get people out they're being arrested
and stopped by the taliban they're truly
continuing to risk that's why our
veterans i think are the true heroes
among us and we don't agree on that well
they're my heroes that's why i wanted to
serve among them
sean you're in congress
we've ended this war we're talking about
administrations what can congress do to
make sure we don't get in this again or
could they have done anything well
listen i i think it's important to take
a look we have we have troops all over
the world um we send people on missions
all the time but i think with
afghanistan a lot of members of congress
and the country lost focus on um the
fight and the war and the purpose of the
war and i think it's important that if
you're going to send men and women into
harm's way you never forget their
missions um and you continually analyze
and review to go you know what are we
what are we here to accomplish what is
the cost and life and treasure and and
make decisions from there and i think uh
this is a message to the congress to to
always stay tuned with the money that
you send and the men that you send um
into these conflicts and for me i mean
four guys
and and uh
five legs i mean that is horrific i've
got a buddy in hayward wisconsin
lumberjack world champion log one world
champion jerry salzman was hit by a
roadside bomb as well lost uh half of
his arm came back after and won the log
one world title i mean guys these you
guys are great and amazing and but but
the consequence of the war has been
cataclysmic and in the way we've left
um i think make a lot of veterans really
angry because if the the question
becomes for what what what was the issue
jessica when president biden stands up
there and he invokes our mental health
as justification for his decisions not
to withdraw but his entire
last two weeks i mean isn't that a
little bit tone deaf doesn't he
understand what seeing 13 veterans
killed and feeling helpless to go help i
mean isn't that what's bothering our
mental health does he not see the
connection there
i
cannot suppose to
understand any great depth the
experience that you've had those men who
you were talking to or the people who
continue to serve for us and we're all
so thankful for that
i think everyone
needs to you know we do this thing where
you quarterback everything like on
twitter on social media right and
they're always those jokes the morning
after something terrible happens like oh
i didn't realize we all woke up foreign
policy experts or we all woke up
you know veterans and but there's really
one group
that stands out from the rest of the we
woke up as groups and it's veterans and
you've noticed it in the coverage that
every time no matter what the opinion is
of the person who's doing the interview
if they hear from a veteran what they're
feeling and it's running counter to
what the host thinks what the
administration thinks you just shut up
because it's an experience that none of
us can even touch and that will be with
you for the rest of your life
and that's why i think it's so important
that we have people who served continue
to serve and they serve in washington
they serve in these incredible
organizations private organizations that
have gotten people out that would not
have gotten out in the first place
and just a tremendous amount of respect
and thanks to you and those men you
interviewed and everyone else who serves
you're just going to see and you already
are a lot of veterans running for public
office no absolutely and i think we have
that that's the unfolding
but even more got people out of
afghanistan that mobilize and i've got a
buddy over there still right now i've
heard from him in four days and i think
he's all right but he's probably doing
god's work
can you tell us more about what we'll
hear this weekend
so yeah these three veterans one of them
is the nephew of george w bush and the
grandson of george h.w bush and he's the
most normal bush i've ever met and i've
only met one other that was president
but his name is
not normal
i'm saying i met him and he goes how's
your head
because he was doing the drop the d
campaign
but and then you have amos benjamin
that's the gold star brother and then
you have chad fleming who's a real
jason bourne style character and this
guy was an amputee in war and uh and
just everything about chad his
leadership and push through it and they
come from different places
and you'll watch the interview and they
kind of have their head hung the whole
time it's it's a tough thing but they
have some inspiring words by the end
look forward to it on behalf of veterans
thank you all for your support it means
a lot it really does i'm praying on it i
pray on it every day no shannon bremo
over there does too i'm with you you can
catch my entire interview this weekend
on the big saturday and the big sunday
show at 5 pm eastern